could you raise four hundred dollars in
an emergency according to the Federal
Reserve Board forty-seven percent of
Americans we'd have to sell something
borrow money or simply couldn't raise
that amount for a thousand-dollar
emergency the number goes up to sixty
percent and I'm not just talking about
people below the poverty line these are
also middle-class Americans living
paycheck to paycheck the biggest issue
many of us just don't say one in five
American families have zero saving
making them extremely vulnerable they
could be one traffic fine are you are
visitor way from huge financial issues
but families who say between 250 and
seven hundred and fifty dollars are less
likely to be evicted from their homes
and are less likely to need public
benefits now if you're a millennial take
a bow because we're leading the way
two-thirds of us are now saving five
percent of our income more than any
other age group so maybe it's time for
you to get on the phone to your parents
and give them a lecture on finances